one of the frequent and painful
paradoxes of romantic life is that the
more we get to know and love someone the
harder it can be to summon up any
sincere wish to sleep with them intimacy
and closeness far from fostering deeper
sexual desire can be the very
ingredients that destroy excitement
whereas having only just recently met a
person and not feeling too much for them
can set up awkward yet compelling
preconditions for wanting very badly to
take them to bed the conundrum is
sometimes colloquially referred to as
the Madonna [ __ ] complex it can sound
offensive and reactionary phrased like
this as if the problem applied to only
one gender and might at some level
condone or even promote the very dynamic
that it describes and yet the phrase
circles something highly significant
always contemporary and of relevance to
every gender it might for heterosexual
women be known as the saint Brut complex
it was Sigmund Freud who first drew
attention to our difficulties connecting
love with desire in an essay of 1912
titled on the universal tendency to
debasement in the sphere of love of many
of his patients he wrote where they love
they have no desire and where they
desire they cannot love in seeking to
explain the division Freud pointed to
two facts connected to our upbringing
first in childhood we are generally
brought up by people we love deeply and
yet towards whom we cannot express
sexual feelings frightened as we are by
a strict incest taboo and second as
adults we tend to choose lovers who in
certain powerful though unconscious ways
resemble those whom we loved most dearly
as children together these influences
set up a devilish conundrum whereby the
more deeply we come to love someone
outside of our family the more strongly
we are reminded of the intimacy of our
early familial bonds and hence are the
less free we instinctively are to
Bres our sexual desires without fear or
reservation an incest taboo originally
designed to limit the genetic dangers of
inbreeding can the succeed in inhibiting
and eventually ruining our chances of
enjoying intercourse with someone to
whom we are not in the remotest way
related the likelihood of the incest
taboos re-emergence with a partner
increases greatly after the arrival of
children until then reminders of the
parental prototypes on which our choice
of lovers is subconsciously based can
just about be kept at bay but once there
is a pram in the hallway and a sweet
infant referring to the person we once
tied up or explored with a sex toy as
mummy or daddy both parties may
significantly start to take fright
complain of feeling tired and turn in
early a dichotomy grows between the pure
things one can do with a partner one
loves and the dirty things one still
longs to do but can only imagine being
free enough to do with a near stranger
it can feel untenable disrespectful to
want to make love to or to put the
matter at its sharpest to [ __ ] the kind
of person who is later going to be
preparing lunch boxes or arranging the
school rotor to start to overcome the
problem it pays to observe that not all
childhoods are equal in their tendencies
to generate sexual difficulties for
people in later life a parent who is
very uncomfortable with their body may
send out covert signals that sex is
invariably dirty bad and dangerous and
thereby lends their child an impression
that it truly can't belong within a
loving relationship a more integrated
and mature parent on the other hand may
suggest that they are reconciled to
their desires and relaxed about some of
the proto sexual things that small
children naturally and innocently do
like make a great deal of noise and mess
take an interest in their bodies and at
a certain age talk about poo a lot the
feeling that one can be naughty and
still loved and good is one of the great
gifts that a parent may bequeath to
their child a lot of the work to repair
the love sex dichotomy can strangely for
something so physical
in the mind we can't conceptually start
a rehabilitate sex as a serious and in
its way entirely respectable topic the
good people who love their children and
their jobs and are invested in
upstanding life can be profoundly
interested in that there need be no
conflict between a longing to be filthy
and depraved at some points and decorous
and respectable at others we can contain
multitudes the us that wants to flog or
be debased or smear and the us that
wants to advise nurture and counsel one
can be a [ __ ] and Madonna brute and
saint
rather than seeking out different
partners we might settle less
disruptively on merely adopting
different roles a child cannot express
love and sexuality to a parent and vice
versa but it is one of the privileges of
adulthood that we no longer have to be
hampered by such a paradigm our lovers
need not be only cozy co-parents and
responsible sweet friends they can for a
time in a very best transgressive sense
also be something that is hugely
important to our mental well-being and a
survival of our relationships partners
in crime
if you enjoyed our film you might be
interested in our range of books on
topics such as relationships to explore
click the link on your screen now
you